ブルー
今日は木強しです
読めます
日本語の方ですエゴいいん
日本語の方
あれで時剛剛って言います
上から下までね今までの人生で一回も読んでもらった頃ない
もう小さい頃からバイヤーを感じていいできました
ん
えっ
今日は1月11日っていうものすごく
私たちのこの後部にとっては特別な大事な日です
私も
今日朝早く起きて長田区にあるある
だいたい毎年行っている公園で朝の5時46分を迎えていい
っていうのはあれから20年あるという間でした
いろんなものが変わったと
この変わらないところまあそれをの方が横していました
えっ
あの紹介いただいたように私は20年もボランティアとか npo
そういうことをやってきました
でその中でこの震災被災というのは大きなテーマであったんですけど今日はその中で
バリアを感じる
震災ということを待つわってバリア
あるいはバリアーに直面するそういうことを皆さんと一緒に
6一緒に考えられたらなと思っています
ちょっといきなりなんですけどうんちょっと皆さんに質問したいと思います
同性の結婚ということについて皆さんの意見を
ちょっと教えてください
男とをそこ今だと思っ
ここにいくつかのちょっとレベルがあります
最初のレベル
同棲で一緒に+性的な関係ももちろんある
同性のカップルですね
でこういう存在についていいと思う方
あかんと思う方まあわからない方はてあげなくても結構です
賛否今からお聞きします
酸性のかと
多いですね
では反対の方
あいますねはい行きがあるはい所作ありがとうございます
かなりの方が今の感じだと手を上げられない方はちょびっという感じですかね
次の質問
これは今のはまあいえば好き嫌いとか a 悪いという個人的な判断ですけど
私たちの社会の制度として
正式の結婚という制度に同性の結婚というのを許容するかどうか今の日本はそれダメ
です
外国にはそれを ok としている国がありますよねすでにね
国とか集とかこれは
異性の従来の男女の結婚であれば例えば
扶養手当とか児童手当とか
育児休業とか
公営住宅への入居とかそういう普通に配偶者
リーは夫婦として認められているものが認められるかどうかって結構大きな
実生活上の話になっています
それが認められないと例えば今言ったこととか遺産を相続するとか
やっぱりは
外国人同性のパートナーが外国人の場合
夫婦として正式に認められていると日本に
配偶者として進めるところがこれが配偶者正式のてっ今でなければビザ在留資格が不安
っていますよね
そういったいろんな非常に来実際的な問題でも
そういうものの中で正式の結婚夫婦として夫婦と言い方がいいかどうか
男と男んだと思うの結婚が日本でも認めてやないか
そういう制度にしましょうということで賛成の方を手を挙げてください
東ヘッダ下部んですかね反対の方
やっぱりハイあのさっきの二人ぐらいよりは倍以上になりますね
でも何人から多分てあげられなかった
3つ目
今度は子どもの問題
同性の間の子供
当然普通にはできませんから養子をもらうかあるいは
そのカップも制しから薄いとアップル街のヒトの卵子加勢して子供を作っ
その子供にも
嫡出非嫡子つっておりますよねあの姫嫡出だとまさにその相続とかいろんな子供と普通
も
普通の夫婦の間の子供として認められる権利がいろいろ認められなくなる
そういうものも
提案同性の間でも子供何らかの形で作って
その子に権利を認めるそういう
日本の制度にして n と思う方賛成反対
はい賛成の方
半分ぐらいですかね簡単な方
あはいありがとうございますあの反対が徐々に増えてきたような感じがしますね
で多分ずっと手を上げられなかった来ないもなぁという方もちらほらんいただきまし
ます
でも明らかに最初の質問ただ一緒に暮らすということからだんだんその賛否が
まあいえば揺れてきましたか
あの震災とか被災とか以来7話が偉いという話な思いとかもしれませんけど
要するに男や女と今基本的な
私たちの伝統的な考えでは基本的な分け方分類が
とかあるいは男らしさ女らしさとか
分類が実は結構相当前でもない人によって感じ方が様々である
あるいはこういう着方によって答え方も皆さんの中でも違ってくる
まあ何が正しいかという話はもちろんないですよ
そういう無礼をちょっとあの
いただきたかった
でこのらしさとか分類とかそういうのは震災の時にもありました
例えば被災者なしか
ボランティアがシートか
被災者という言葉で皆さんどういうイメージをもたれるか
あのもう出ましたけどまぁ被災していろんなものを失ったり傷ついたり
それは目に見える
家族を失った家を失った仕事を失った
ミニ見えない
何かものすごく大きな喪失感
大切な人を失った思い出を失った
そういうことでコーム力になる人の助けを必要としたり
キリッとしてい
そういう被災者というイメージありますよね
じゃあコメントどう思われますか
もんぷゆ
そんなに文とか要求する強く持つこうしてくれー
要求要望する強く自己主張するこういう被災者
これも皆さん被災者らしいという感じします
もちろんあの創造考えれば分かるように生身の人間ですから
あのすべてのことに満足しているわけはないしいろんな善意のボランティアとか
酒井かの全員の支援
もっとこうして欲しいとかそんなしてほしくないとか
切符そういう話はあると思うんですよね
あの東日本これは阪神から東日本にちょっと飛びますけど
東日本の豆腐も方が頭からいろんな人が支援に入った
でっ
あの神戸から東北にたくさんの人が入ってて結構みんな頭の人やっぱり暑いですね後部
8-1
自分たちの経験もあるから
で
ついわかるよ私たちも同じ体験したからわかるよ
言ってしまう
これ実は結構評判悪いですね
わかります
あの阪神の震災も確かにものすごいものすごい被害で巨大な災害でした
でも
東日本ね津波があり原発があり
かなりやっぱり違う部分があるんです
津波って本当にこういう表現はあんまり良くないと思いますけど本当に町が根こそぎ
根こそぎ町がなくなってしまうような
それを
私たちも同じ台を分かるよって
ね簡単に言われたくないっていう声は私何度か聞きました
多分これ皆さんも想像したらわかりますよねなんかこう辛い時とか悩んでいる時に
分かるよ
簡単に言われたらのほうがいいわかるか
あの言いたくなるような
もう一つ
これは被災者の人から私言われても2足づつキープしたことがあります
被災者というのは
と
何ヶ月も何ヶ月も何ヶ月もありがとうと言い続けないといけない
じっちゃんそのしんどさが分かるか
入っちゃって感じですね
どんだけ神ということが分かるか
やっぱり支援される側する側
がっつい別れてしまう数がはボランティアであるいろいろブッシュを打ってくれる方で
あれみんな全員ですよね
良かれと思ってする
でもそれに常に座にありがとうと言わないといけない
あるいはたまには書いて欲しいそこじゃないわとか
そこ触ったりたいねソーランと言ってとか
うんそう思っても
ね全員の人になかなかいい難いですよね
そういう時にもありがとうって言わなきゃいけないようなそういう
プレッシャーあるいはそういう関係性が支援するされるという中で生まれてしまう
そのしんどさわかるかと言われたときにはすごくてなんかすごくず切符しました
えっ
ボランティアということでもお兄さんのことがあります
ボランティアよくボランティアというイメージですかね
まぁちょっとこれは変なヒロブ正しく美しく
まあ頑張って支援してでもこう
これも文句を言わない黙々と
人のサポートし続け
ボランティアもいろんな支援しているとこれは別にこの人の問題とかを私たちもこの
当事者とボランティアで支援せてでもそれじゃあ解決につかない世の中全体の問題って
歩いちゃうの
社会の精度とか仕組み変えると赤のちゃうのと思うことってやっぱりあるんですよね
でもそういうこと言うと何や名前きな
っていう感じさっきの被災者の人が
要求をしにくい見たような構造
つまり何何ら四季彩舎が c 歳車
ボランティアらしいボランティア
そこからちょっとでも
皆さん皆さん一般的な社会がそのらしさ
を求めてくるのから外れたらしくなさの側に回るとどういう言い方になります
らしさが何のにらしいボランティアらしい
に対してい
何なりのくせに言い方にすぐ出てきますよね
これでも皆さんもえん
経験ありません
ん男のくせにとか女のくせにとか
若い苦戦最近ヨプを聞くのは日本人の口セグか
そういう
世間のらしさからちょっとでも外れるとそういうマルシュのプレッシャーというか
難しくよと同調圧力というか
そういうのがループあるような気がします
自分自身の話をします
私あのー阪神の震災から鯉世界に会いに10年くらい
わりとすぐにもうある母の団体で
ショップとして働き始めたんですねまぁ臨時の食みたいなもんですけど
かなり長いこと親とか親戚からはいつまでボランティアステンの
以内にやっぱり言われます
と言われました
なかなかその親の世代の世界観これもまああんまり一括りにしちゃいけないまさにこれ
もあの決めつけでありカテゴライズなんですけどでも多くの親の世代からするという風
に理解できないんですねこういう生き方
でもまぁ息子が生き生きと楽しそうに生きているとそれは見てわかってくれたんですか
なかなか理解受け入れられないでっ
椅子になったらまともな仕事を探すのとか
感じがあります
でまぁ私は車の好き勝手減ったように行ってきたからいいんですが
そういう何何らしさみたいなものが人何かに押し込める窮屈な
機作りと抑圧するものがまああるのかもしれません
じゃそのらしさのさらにを行く前にある
カテゴリーとか分類ということ
被災者被災者
ねっ例えば家が全壊した半壊した被災者と呼ばれます
でも家は全然大丈夫あるいは自分も大丈夫
例えば
兵庫県にいなかった京都に住んでたっ
自分の体もメロン家屋も
物理的にもなく自分の家族も何も大丈夫
でも自分は物凄い小さい頃からの最高の無二の親友が神戸にいて
そいつを震災で亡くした
その日と言います
その人の喪失感
下手な下手な物理的な
ねあの経済的な損失よりもはるかに重い
ものを抱え続ける人の中にはいい
そうなってくると被災者が被災者じゃないたという分類も
ほとんど意味なくなるわけですよね
まあ版記載車
そんな彼はけどわからない方になり
結局カテゴリーとかカテゴライズすることということの限界があるのかな
でも人間何かで分類しないとカテゴリーしない
カテゴライズしないと現実とが捕らえられない
良い悪いじゃなくて多分カテゴライズというのは誰もが常に行っていることです
男でやる女である
何神である
でもたとえばここに100人の人がいたら100の人生がある
現実のほうが絶対人間ですよね
でも分類というのは常にいう間
これは多分言葉が有限であるというのはたぶん同じなんでしょう
言葉で分類しないといっ
でも現実の方は常に6ゲーム
何それを麦してカテゴライズしようとするとそこからいろんなものがこぼれ落ちる
無理矢理自分は分類されてしまったという気持ちに多くの人をさせる
そういう時に入っ
カテゴライズしてしまうことで失われるものそこからこぼれ落ちるもの
それにどこまで自分が自覚的になれるか
ということかなと思います
自分自身も多分カテゴライズしてしまっています
常に誰も多分しています
ただカテゴライズしてしまうことに自覚的になって
そこから外れるその人ならではのその人しか持ってない
その人らしさ
難しく井戸その人の誇りとか尊厳とか可能性
それに少しどうしても分離しないといけないこともあるかもしれない
そういう時でも少し想像力をはたらかしてみる
その人ならではの書外のものないものなんだろう
そうすることでカテゴリーの乱暴な
決めつけてしまうところ何何らしい言って人を押し込みてしまう
自分追走してしまうところから
少しでも自由になれるんじゃないかなと思います
カテゴリーから少し離れて見る
そうすると
人に対して
少し優しくなれるその人もありのままを少しでも受け取れるようになるんじゃないか
それはたぶん
もしかしたら自分自身自分のありのまま
いろんな分類されてそそる分類しきれないんだ私は
っていう思ってしまう自分自身の
こぼれてしまうところを第一にすることにも
つながるんじゃないかと私は思います
ありがとうございました